[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
or or he just uh he would just say i'm
gonna do it and she says no you're right
i don't care
i'll forget it
cut that part out cut that part
i'm blushing because the joke didn't
work that thank you
i'm gonna [ __ ] fight you you don't
understand what i was even trying to say
that has to stay
i didn't even understand what i was
trying to say so cut that out if you cut
that out we have a [ __ ] problem
you long ago
my penis went straight yeah
okay
and through years of leaning it to my
left it's crumpled right
it now it looks like an eiffel tower
yeah okay
crumpled
[Laughter]
me and andrew auditioned for this
opening up we didn't get the part but
five times yeah we read five
who are you auditioning to be um jimmy
young and ken jung's part
they both picked me out yeah but it's a
lot of aids but it's a funny it's a
funny movie it's got great people in it
bill burr
tom
yeah and you didn't get it um i didn't
get it it's fine you know hopefully one
day steve will use me i actually i
watched it the other day yeah and uh
this is a weird thought to have yeah
and but i'm being totally honest with
you yeah yeah
i enjoyed that you weren't in it
[Laughter]
like at the end of the movie i was like
i'm glad bobby wasn't
yeah i was like okay so much better
that's good i knew a hot guy who was
struck by lightning and he needed to um
he was very still very highly [ __ ]
but he didn't have a weird lightning
voice
i can't say his name but this is really
his name yep but i remember my friend
and i were like oh my god that's got
that guy so hot we went over i was like
hey you know like my name's so-and-so
and he's like my name is
[Laughter]
but he's still hot really but he's still
hot mm-hmm
half asian guy and um my friend still
made out with him didn't care all right
yeah wait do you where you just saw him
like sitting around somewhere he was at
a party we were younger it was like a
friend's like house party and so you're
like you knew he was already hit by
lightning no we didn't oh so you're just
this guy's hot let's go talk yeah and
then later on
[Music]
like he's talking to you he had to put a
machine to his throat like yeah like
it's kind of like to uh magnify the
voice oh so he was like but you know um
yeah he was just yeah but when you're in
bed you know it doesn't matter right
yeah yeah it really does
it's good he's gonna make fun you know
what he puts the mic to it i'm going to
come
yeah
oh yeah feels good
but imagine that
feels good imagine if you had sex with
him
and then he he uh he doesn't pull out
and you're like did you come inside me
he's like
sorry about that
dude you got to [ __ ] tell me i didn't
want to stop tell you
right yeah he couldn't stop because yeah
he's like i don't want to yeah i want to
go grab the machine
right stop having sex where do you want
me to come like [ __ ] yeah that's
something you guys ever do like
star-crossed lovers like you're um she's
an uh an isis princess and you're like a
us soldier we role-play
yeah yeah we role-play where we have
these characters she's uh trish and i'm
bobby and uh like i'm at a bar
and she's like just this piece of [ __ ]
alcoholic that hangs out like a total
scumbag yeah and then i'm this guy who
she's like trying to hook up with yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] about her yeah i say
her name wrong yeah
that's funny yes i'll be like tammy and
she's like it's trish
[Laughter]
as soon as i finish like as soon as the
last bit is done yeah i go get out like
that and like i'll throw a pillow in her
face and she's like i love her shut the
[ __ ] up
that's how we woke up that's the best
yeah she changed she does [ __ ] live we
do dorm room stuff like no no no no we
we will have be having sex and then the
sketch will start right so we're doing
it and then she'll go
um hey hey um teacher why you know i
mean we don't do teacher we do dorm
rooms and you're like my dad's hands up
the camera no no we don't do camp cancer
stuff he's my dad's um business partner
and he visits me in my dorm that's my
favorite
yeah i think another one we do incest
stuff like uncle and thanksgiving that's
pretty cute we don't do anything
so cute
we don't do ancestors you know what you
should do for the dorm room
or bestiality you should lean on a dog
we should lean in the room be like oh
hey man uh i don't know how to set up my
internet here
like
you've been in this forum for a while
and you'll be like yeah you're saying
that yeah yeah i'll help set you up and
then you [ __ ] get under a computer
yeah yeah she's like oh i feel like i
owe you now be like well you kind of
[ __ ] do owe me yeah
but holy maybe you can try east coast
indians today no maybe it's ghost indian
why don't you do in new york why don't
you do one without what i want what the
[ __ ] do you want um blind deaf blind and
dead
wait that means i can still talk right
yeah but apparently like yeah yeah you
got to do it with like a weird accent
yeah i got the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
i'm hard now okay okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you guys are gonna do it
tonight yeah yeah and then when i once i
go in what are you gonna say
is that your take
just like that are you turned on
yeah i could feel it
if you landed on your head and you had a
slur right how long
do would we have to wait to make fun of
you well people would have right away no
i wouldn't have i would have waited at
least six months six months and they had
you on and got like how i feeling and
then just mocked you you know now i'm
[ __ ] thai or something like
so
whatever
no i i yeah people would admit i mean
you know we're comics we would have yeah
i don't think i don't i don't need to
say i don't think i would
i'd feel so devastated it would be it
would be devastating the people close to
me would be [ __ ] up because you guys
would all be like
that could be you'd be like oh yeah that
could be us you know like people who and
i'm sitting here being like
how's everybody doing tonight oh
my god and then i have to convince you
after shows like no that was really good
oh yeah right and i just get like
i get a bunch of like pity
pity and then you all your jokes would
have to be kind of revolved around the
slur
oh yeah i mean oh of course yeah yeah
yeah yeah it would be like an hour of
like yeah
everybody talks different
that's a good one well it would just be
like a new
like madonna it's just a new look a new
look yeah yeah the slur guy though
oh my god i get i'd get invited to like
those like speech impediment seminars
like you guys can be successful
you know i was bad at like all that
stuff is that um i hated putting forth a
big effort so ryan my whole thing
when i was dating would be like
you know i would
put forth some effort yeah and if i like
it wasn't reciprocated i was like
there's no way i'm gonna put more energy
is he a good uh partner to your aunt
yeah yeah he's he he makes her laugh he
makes her laugh
obviously
a wonderful lover as well yeah you've
heard about that yeah you met my rabbit
style
is that what you're saying i was just
making oh yeah yeah and then you know
you know how you know how girls are
always like i just want a guy who's
funny yeah right but but and then once
they get the guy that's funny they
realize you also need other
characteristics
yeah yeah yeah and so
she has she's like he's funny
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no i have other skill sets that say yeah
what are they okay i'm going to tell you
um
i'm funny
yeah you know
i'm also the one we have covered okay
here's another thing i do i don't have a
problem with her
what
what
i don't have a problem with her
what do you mean there's nothing that
she does that bothers me
kurosawa
nothing bothers you about her not really
you know i mean it's like i i let things
pass by like what's like a thing that
could bother you but you're like i'll
just i'm not gonna say anything
well she does she thinks that i'm um
that i have um
she thinks that i'm not coordinated
okay
but that's not real so she'll say stuff
like um
be careful walking down the stairs
in my mind i'm like [ __ ] i've walked
down so many [ __ ] stairs you know
you'll [ __ ] know i'm a stair master
[ __ ] but you keep your at your mouth i
keep my mouth shut and so then i'll walk
down the street and you know i mean and
be careful yeah right to be very
wonderful what your weight for some
reason your weight you do lean forward
when you walk yeah so wait what do you
weigh
oh my god
it's top heavy i'm top heavy i weigh
about 175.
that's it yeah but four live four four
eleven four eleven that's not good
175 yeah how much do you weigh
235 yeah yeah but you're tall how tall
are you six eight yeah yeah there you go
yeah yeah
other koreans are like what do you think
will happen next yeah what's your next
boyfriend if we break up
uh well let me think about this um
i've basically dated every single race
really but i haven't done a new yorker
indian guy and i've been eyeballing them
lately really
yeah like
off the boat indian no i knew you an
indian raised in new york oh i got you
not an ellie his parents let's say are
indian but he's raised in new york
but not i'm not saying aziz but like you
know just that flavor kind of right uh
the east coast yeah indian oh go for it
i've never done that i mean i'm not you
know
just i'm just throwing it out there
i mean i think ask me dude ask me
well you're back to white chicks i know
you're done with asian no be real ask me
okay bobby what's next
nothing you're done
i really believe that oh well then i'm
[ __ ] done too bro you asked me the
question i i
i truly believe that without her
it's i can't there's nothing
yeah this would be there's no east coast
indian
[ __ ] this would be the most amazing
time for you to leave him like right now
yeah
i probably slept i don't know an hour or
two i just i'm so curious to know what
christina was like what she was saying
she was i think she was kind of
overwhelmed because like the christians
came and like
set stuff up in this room and you know
[ __ ] burnt even like you know how
[ __ ] up i was yeah next to the
nightstand he put a
jar of vitamin c and uh and calcium for
your bones
[Laughter]
and uh and then snacks
he put all types of snacks like doritos
the [ __ ] is all this yeah yeah in case
you get hungry like yeah cheetos and she
knows i'm not eating this [ __ ] man i'm
like wow who's in the board who's on the
board yeah
um yeah bill al
bill burr you ari shafir bert kreischer
how magical al magical and maybe
somebody else that's the board yeah
that's amazing he has um a paranoia that
somehow he's gonna get kicked off of all
things comedy because of the board you
were telling this to ari yeah why why
would they kick you off i don't know i
just don't trust boards
there's something suspicious about it
i've seen movies where there's a board
corporate but
here's my question let's say they're
like tomorrow you get the call and i go
hey i couldn't say it on there but we're
kicking you off um what happens like why
this is what let's do that phone call
now okay go ahead hello hey bobby it's
tom oh what's up dude you're great on
the podcast last night dude thank you i
had a great time okay um hey i wanted to
tell you something i couldn't say it's
when we were doing the podcast yeah
but i was talking to the other guys on
the board
and uh
you guys got you got to go we're gonna
we're gonna take you off why
i'm i don't know we just kind of we're
thinking it over
like uh we kind of like other people all
right well can i just still throw this
out there yeah sure to you um
i know what our numbers are yeah
all right and this is what i would say
okay you want me real yeah let's be real
i know what our numbers are okay and i
know the numbers on all the other
podcasts that you
have yeah and we kill it we kill them
okay right yeah we do yeah we [ __ ] do
all right all right all right
no no we [ __ ] do and also number
number number two i gotta turn it uh
yeah number nine
let me say this okay let me
let me do that all right yeah bert you
rogan now rogan al bill you guys are my
friends yeah
i know it's not here's the thing
it's
it's not personal ah it's here's the
here's why uh-huh we just thought it
would be
fun
to upset you
oh
all right all right all right well i'm
upset and i'm glad you're having fun
yeah um
that's cool we'll go on on our merry way
yeah but by the way yeah we don't want
you back
okay all right okay all right i feel
like you'd be so good at firing people
yeah yeah i'm actually worried but you
know
i could i would be good at in a pretend
capacity okay but no not if you really
thought someone's livelihood was on but
now we hang up right this is what
happens all right now hey so bobby no
one last thing yeah eat a pile of [ __ ]
all right
i've been with someone with a micropeen
i know this isn't a line i really i
swear to god i and i blew him to
completion
yeah he was and he was like one of those
gums with a little liquid in it i
promise we couldn't have sex because he
had a microphone so i just blew him and
i really liked him i honestly was
genuinely in love with him give you a uh
a big like warning like in other words
was there a lot no just day of he's just
like there it is yeah but i think that
he ah you guys i'm telling you that i
could jerk them off like this
wow one finger this is not an
exaggeration what's mine my three
fingers no you're actually the average
size you're not the smallest thank you
but that's a fact thank you
that's out there
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]